PITTSBURGH.
FIRING THE PUCK AT WILL. POINT T
HOME IN 32 YEARS.
AND SHOT.
AND BROBERG IS STOP AND WAITING
AND THROWN OFF TO THE GAMES WITE
AND JUST DON'T GO IN THE HEAD.
A LOT OF G SAVE
REIMER.
SECOND SHOT THE
CREASE.
BUT THE SHARKS COULDN'T GET THE
REBOUND OFF.
OUT BY YAMAMOTO.
HYMAN SKATES IT INTO.
HE IS IN AND DENIED
AND SOUTH CARNT-HOPKINS
ALL ALONE.
LOOK AT THIS.
YAMAMOTO IN FRONT.
AND THEN HE FOLLOWS IT UP ON THE
REBOUND.
YAMAMOTO HAS BEEN REALLY
EFFECTIVN KEITH.
HERET TO HYMAN WHO MAKES A
BEAUTIFUL PLAY OVER TO
7:00.AIT
SHARKS IN DEEP.
BORDELEAU.
BURNS THENE HITS THE BAR.
THIS ONE YOU OF
FERRARO.
GIVEN BACK TO
>> MCDAVID.
AROUND FERRARO.
BEAUTIFUL PASS.
SHOT NUGENT-HOPKINS.
EXTENDS THE BIG PADDLE TO THE
POKE CHECK AT THE LAST SECOND T.
I'M USUALLY PRETTY GOOD WITH
THAT.
IF HE WAS A TOUGH GUYUST TRIES D
OFF FOEGELE.
>> WELL SAID GENE.OARDS.
KOSKINEN IS FOLLOWINGI'VE LIVEDW
.
GUESS WHO IS THE START LEON
DRAISAITL AND CONNOR MCDAVID IN
HERTL. AWAY.
[ Horn ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> EDMONTON